Anyone who's going to spend the
time and effort to learn a language
should understand how the process
works and there is no better
explainer than Stephen krashen.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here today.
Today, I'm going to talk about
Stephen Krashen and the theory
of language acquisition.
Remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notific...
notifications.
And if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a review.
I appreciate it.
So, uh, I mentioned Steven Krashen in one
of my previous videos, and I said that
he has put out a book, a thin book, uh,
which really, he says all there is that
we need to know about language acquisition
and someone asked, what is the book?
Well, actually there are quite a few books
and I would recommend that people Google
for Stephen Krashen go to his website and
you'll find all kinds of free material.
And I think it's important for people
who are interested to learn a language,
interested in language learning, that they
understand how the process works and the
best explainer of how we learn languages
in my opinion, by far, is Stephen Krashen.
And, uh, so I was gonna, I thought
I would do one or several videos
where I walk through some of his
explanations about language learning.
So this is a book that I got
in Taipei when I was there
I don't know, 15 years ago.
And he was presenting there and I didn't
know him, but I listened to him and
it was kind of like a Eureka moment.
And I bought this book.
So let's just start here and it's not like
I'm reading from the Bible, but almost.
So the principles of language acquisition.
First of all the following five
hypotheses, you know, explanations of
how we learn are the core of current
theory on language acquisition.
First of all, the acquisition
learning hypothesis claims that
we have two independent ways
of developing language ability.
One is language acquisition as
a subconscious process and the
second one is a deliberate effort,
the way we learn in school.
And his point is that we learn primarily
naturally in a, as a subconscious process
and that the rules and the grammar that we
learn at school don't help us very much.
The second hypothesis is the natural order
hypothesis, which states that there is
a natural or.der with which we're going
to acquire the elements of a language.
And there's a natural order, uh, for
acquiring certain elements of grammar.
And it doesn't necessarily relate
to how simple or complex those
particular grammar issues are.
And he uses the example of the sort
of progressive form in English.
The "...ing" I'm going, learning,
doing versus the third person singular,
which takes an "s" as we know.
Takes an "s" takes an "s".
So even though the idea that the third
person singular in the present tense takes
an "s" is a very simple concept, it takes
a long time for most language learners,
people learning English to acquire.
Whereas the "...ing" form, that
continuous or the progressive
form, is acquired very early.
And studies have shown that a number of
issues in grammar in different languages
seem to be acquired in the same order
and it doesn't really matter how much
effort is put into teaching these.
It's not because something
is taught that we acquire it
because there is a natural order.
And so the natural order is not
based on simplicity or complexity,
it's immune to deliberate teaching.
And so the, and the correlary in a
way is that, you know, the natural
order is not the teaching order.
So you may still teach different
things, but it's going to be acquired
according to this natural order.
The third element of his
language acquisition theory is
the monitor hypothesis and the
conscious sort of teaching of the
language  creates in us a monitor.
Here are the correct rules.
Here is how the language is spoken,
but he makes the point that the
monitor, our knowledge of grammar can
make only a very small contribution
to language acquisition, because
there are so many rules of grammar.
And so few people who know all the rules.
The idea that the learner will know
the rule when he or she needs to
use it, will remember the rule.
If the learner spends their time
and effort on thinking about the
rule and I"'m about to say this
now, let's think about the rule.
Is this correct?"
They won't be able to speak
because it's just simply too
difficult to do while speaking.
So the monitor, if anything,
can actually inhibit speaking.
So the monitor, uh, as a means of,
you know, improving our knowledge
of a language is not very effective.
Okay.
The next thing is the input
or comprehension hypothesis.
We, we learn languages when we
understand the message, when we're
interested in a message and we
understand the message comprehensible
input is the only thing that works
says Krashen in language acquisition.
We have tried grammar rules.
We have tried repetition drills and
the input hypothesis, uh, claims,
however, that comprehending messages
is the only way language is acquired.
There is no individual variation
in the fundamental process
of language acquisition.
And then he goes on to explain
that we acquire language to input
when we already have enough things
that we have already acquired.
So that I plus one, we, we acquired
that next thing that we could learn.
We can learn once we have acquired
sort of the previous things.
And so we learned from context.
And therefore the teaching method
has to be focused on giving
learners comprehensible input.
Now a corollary of the, uh,
input hypothesis is that
talking is not practicing.
In other words, you can't output
your way to language acquisition.
It is the input that's going to
give you the language acquisition.
If you get enough input, then you
will have that situation, sort of N+1,
because we'll be getting so much input
that there will be elements there that
you are already familiar with that
will enable you then to learn some
additional elements with enough input.
Now, immediately, people are going
to say, well, when you first start,
you don't understand anything.
And so Krashen in this book explains
how in a classroom, this sort
of total physical response TPR.
It's a method in the classroom where
the teacher can simplify the language
content, can use gestures, can use
pictures, can use a whole range of
things to help the learner start to
get a toehold in the language, create
that N or he refers to it as I, so that
incrementally additional things can
then be added to what is understood.
I happen to believe, with a system
like LingQ, and people are going to
criticize me, but the idea that we can
create that same sheltered environment,
even for people who are not in a
classroom, uh, using say the mini stories
where there's a lot of repetition of
vocabulary, you can look words up, you
can listen again, you can read again.
Somewhere, you have to get
a start in the language.
You have to get a start.
Initially, nothing is comprehensible.
You have to start to acquire little
bits and pieces so that you can then
build on that with additional things
that start to become comprehensible.
And so the complexity of what you're
listening to, it gets greater and greater
as you're able to expand into new domains.
I think I'll stop it there.
He has a lot of research
to back up what he said.
But I, I just think it's it's well
worthwhile anyone who's going to spend
the time and effort to learn a language
should understand how the process works.
And there is no better
explainer than Stephen Krashen.
So whether it be this particular
book or whether you simply go to
his website and download all of the
free material that's there, I'll
leave a link in the description
box, I very much suggest you do it.
And, uh, I think armed with this
sense of how we learn, like, even
if we think we're not progressing,
it's obvious from what Krashen writes
based on all of his research and
experience, as long as we continue to
expose ourselves to the language, we
will continue to gradually improve.
Okay.
I thought I'd just bring you up to
date on, on where you can get some
more information about Stephen Krashen,
because there were questions about that.
Thank you.